now that everything's becoming like
hyper federalized
what do we get republicans have to at
the federal level democrats have to at
the federal level
and we get to the point where both sides
continually increase the rhetoric
against the other
as they become more and more different
and more and more opposed to each
other's world view
than hatred fear and eventually violence
so which brings me to this next story
business insider says
uh according to business insider tucker
carlson mocks alexandria ocasio-cortez
for thinking she might die
during the capital riot in which five
people died you see how they do that
headline
look i i i i can't speak to as you know
to what
ocasio-cortez is feeling or fearing but
we also have this story out from nbc
where they said
some democrats think their colleagues
want to kill them
or will kill them or whatever aoc said
she
narrowly escaped with her life or
narrowly avoided death
she said that she wasn't sure if she
should go into the secure chamber
because these
her colleagues may reveal her location
to the far right and white supremacists
and she literally calls
members of congress far right white
supremacists
white supremacist sympathizers and that
is insane
they're not they're just republicans but
that kind of rhetoric of the other being
an
evil villain where they view them not as
just a conservative
but as literally a white supremacist and
then saying she thinks she will die
is some of the most extreme rhetoric
i've ever heard in my life why are they
throwing around the racial supremacy
stuff
because it's it's a tribal signal like
you know you know
it's literally the coded language that
the left has said the right uses
non-stop
except there and some folks on the right
use code language
but they're very clearly using
not even close to subtle language here
they're flatly calling someone
a white supremacist and i take you know
as a jew
if you tell me someone is a nazi i'm
going to have a slightly different
response than the average person and so
when you call someone a white
supremacist
i would argue especially because it's
being done in bad faith
you are trying to incite violence it's
not merely trying to demonize the other
side for political gain which is clearly
their intent
i just don't think they're thinking it
all the way through
you know there's the the right many on
the right will call the left
communists or you know far left or
whatever socialists
and then i see a lot of comments from
actual leftists where they're like
you know conservatives call joe biden
far left and that's absurd and i'm like
that
that absolutely is absurd joe biden is
establishment corporatist crony he's not
far left
but there's a big difference between
saying ocasio-cortez
is a socialist because she is and her
saying
they're white supremacists one of those
is maybe hyperbolic one of those
is extreme bad faith meant to manipulate
and lie
so i was thinking about this i keep
hearing about the double standard
i've reported on the double standard the
media will say
the peaceful protests the media will
stand in front of a burning building and
say
it's it's i i i know i know about the
fire
but it's mostly peaceful right and then
you get
one event with trump supporters i'm not
talking about the capital and they'll
say
violent extremists and terrorists and
they'll amp it up to him you know you
know tenfold
and i was thinking about this there's no
point in acting like we should be
shocked by this
it was a ares racino so i'm probably
pronouncing your name wrong i would say
that
he wrote for unheard that conservatives
should stop whining about this
there's no debate anymore the left does
not care
you've got two sides that want their
riders to be protected and want the
other rioters to be arrested
right but i do think it's fair to point
out conservatives
are on the on the losing end of this
because for too long they didn't realize
the game the left was playing
democrats and leftists say say this
exact same thing of republicans
but republicans keep taking democrats at
their word
every step of the way democrats don't
they'll come out and say these riots are
the voice
it's the language of the unheard and
that you have to understand their anger
and then if any trump supporters come
out and just stand on the cap on the
steps of the capitol building in
michigan
they scream terrorist you're a terrorist
when when you have far leftists marching
you actually get conservatives defending
their right to free speech
saying well you know they have the right
to speak and then when they smash
windows and burn buildings down
conservatives complain and the left says
nothing
so i was wondering myself at what point
will conservatives have to realize
the left isn't playing by any rules it's
just manipulation of those who are
unwilling to learn
or have no idea what's going on i think
actually conservatives realized this a
while ago without
you know voting for donald trump which
which brings me back to
you're saying voters not politicians
yeah like the like the voters realized
what was going on and said give me trump
and so i there was a comment we got a
super chat a while ago where they said
that when you have two factions and one
is willing to use force to take what
they want and the other isn't
well then you just you'll have a
conflict but when both sides when the
other side decides they're going to
start fighting back
then you have a war well that's where we
are now right
it's not it's not i'm not saying hot war
in the sense of like literal like people
marching
battle on a battlefront i mean you have
democrats
who have been by any means necessary
trying to take power
they they literally say those words and
republicans kept acting like
there was a fair game here so the
example is universal condemnation
conservatives and democrat republicans
and democrats conservatives and liberals
about over the capital riots black lives
matter
only conservatives there's clearly
someone not here playing the game
and so as long as conservatives keep
assuming that there's an actual game to
be played they'll keep losing
i i think there's a calculation from
republicans
that will be by allowing it to go on
the voters will get sick of it and
connect the dots
on their own or by pointing it out
they'll connect the dots and get sick of
it and vote these people out
and i think the instincts there are
correct i think what was not calculated
was the trump
effect because trump is very disruptive
to
the traditional way we have our leaders
how they act he was
by being so open on twitter for example
and i i say this about him all the time
where he is the most transparent
president we've ever had
because he just tweets his thoughts but
that makes him very vulnerable
that makes it very easy to go after him
it makes it very easy to say he is too
disruptive and then you've got someone
like a joe biden because remember
when you had all the democrats coming
out there were a whole bunch of people
who were very very very far to the left
and joe biden joe biden was the one who
came out
because i think people instinctively
understood
that they didn't want to go very very
very far because they
did that once with trump from a
personality perspective
and it didn't turn out so well in their
view they wanted to calm things down
and so i do think and we'll find this
out in two years
d is that the was it trump that got in
the way
of a republican strategy to sort of sit
back point out all
of the biases point out the double
standards point out how crazy they are
and just let them hurt them i think he
did because he would get on twitter and
be
like the far leftists are something
something
galvanizing this group of people and
turning them into this
faction and he was the president and he
would
say that there was a far left movement
and there wasn't but then he
helped create one there's definitely a
far left movement i think
he tried in the way it wasn't organized
until he started talking
about giving them something to all hate
bro you just didn't see it
it's been going on for a long long time
well i was on the ground occupying
walking i watched what these people were
doing and it was even before occupying i
was at occupy i wasn't a far left
extremist and you weren't paying
attention to the facilities down with
the federal reserve
no no no absolutely not bro facilitators
who took over
were intersectional i saw that dude they
own i was told i couldn't speak because
i was white
exactly they took it over i watched this
all happen that was
years before trump that was five years
trump is not the cause of trump didn't
turn
people into this he was he's a symptom
of what's happening he just galvanized
it
i don't think so i think he's a
manifestation of the anger people were
experiencing
and that's why he's an imperfect avatar
he was just the guy who was there
that people put their anger into the
system was broken
their jobs were shipped away free trade
took these things from them
and they saw the game wasn't being
played fairly yes for the people who
voted for him
and the one thing that we all have to
remember is he did not win the popular
vote
which i do think puts a little bit of a
wrinkle in that argument because he won
based on the electoral college vote
and he narrowly and it was a smart
strategy the way that he did it
and he definitely connected with those
voters who felt exactly that way
but when we go from a popular vote
perspective we can't simply ignore that
part for that explanation and that's why
i i still think you throw him out it was
an anomaly
election it was he is an anomaly
candidate
which is why he didn't win a second time
i don't necessarily blame the pandemic
uh obviously it did not help i do think
that when you have four years of the
media that goes after the guy
on everything that he does it does wear
on people and i said 74 million votes
the
most of any sitting president i think
the contributing factor was the media
was screaming you turned on any news
outlet
except for fox news i guess and just
imagine brian stopped going
the whole time and so finally people are
like make it stop make it stop
and then you got regular people who
didn't care were forced into the
political world because of the coveted
lockdowns
they couldn't go out they couldn't
socialize i know i know some people
who have no business being in politics
they only tweet about it now and i'm
like
dude you're you're you're a mechanic
you've never talked this before in your
life
and all of a sudden you're like the
democrat cheerleader when the lockdowns
happen
their normal communication was disrupted
the normal things they cared about the
video games the movies the sports
so they go on social media where it's
all politics all the time and then you
force people into this room where
everyone's just screaming
and then they beg it to stop and they
vote for joe biden
yeah look i 100 agree with people
wanted a reset to calm things down i
think trump would have won
uh if there was no covet if that didn't
happen
obviously trump would have won because
we had moody's analytics
numerous polls forecasters predicting a
trump victory off of standard metrics
when coveted hit a few of them still
predicted a trump victory but many of
them backed away because the economy was
in the gutter
and as they say it's the economy stupid
but i think the biggest factor was
and it's partly uh i think well i should
say partly in many ways trump's fault
trump really went after the media he
made it very personal for them yeah
and he played to their egos and
weaponized that and that
turned them against him to an extreme
degree he did that to people
just common people too well because
trump was like the media it's lying it's
fake news
and he was constantly digging into them
and going after them they decided to
make the fight personal
and so jon stewart brought it up he said
trump played you know
these journalists are very egotistical
so when trump called you know says
something
they take it personally and go after
i've honestly never seen a president be
so
antagonistic since nixon nixon was hated
the hippies in the black panther
movement so bad
and they did impeach nixon
you could argue that obama was
antagonistic to the right he criticized
he was saying a lot of similar things
about fox news it was in a different way
right yeah you're right he wasn't
overtly like on twitter being like those
far right
there was no twitter oh yeah there was
twitter with uh
at the time when obama came in twitter
was
not prominent at all he wasn't using his
influences to like talk
about the far right this is the first
president to use
twitter throughout an entire term and
even though i think it's probably
the wrong way to use it we don't really
know if it was the wrong way or not
because he's the first person to do it
no i think i think there's uh i've
talked to a lot of people
throughout the past several years and
most of the regular people i've spoken
to would say
you know the ones that supported him
yeah you know i voted for him but i just
wish he wouldn't tweet
yeah and then he would and people would
roll their eyes
and that was it he gave he gave so much
fuel
to the media to complain about i mean
there were people journalists whose job
was to wait for their phone to buzz with
a trump tweet
people built careers being reply guys to
trump
and that kept the cycle going if trump
just didn't tweet for one month and said
nothing
the news cycle would be forced down
their twitter reply guys would be out of
business
but trump couldn't let it go there's
like a phenomenon where you become
addicted to pain i don't know if you
guys have ever felt like you have like a
sore shoulder and then all of a sudden
one day you change your posture your
shoulder's not sore anymore and you miss
tweaking it so you go ahead and you
tweak it again and the soreness comes
back and you're like oh there's that
familiar
have you guys ever done that no no i'm
alone in the room here
so like it has a lot to do with posture
like there's an addiction to
to feeling something whether it's good
or bad
and i think people felt like that with
trump's tweets trump trump would say
something because the media would lie
and then he found his way to speak to
the people directly
so then he would tweet out that's not
true that's fake news
then the people who don't actually care
about trump these like these reply bots
and reply guys
build a career off it what happens is
then they end up getting 700 000
followers
building a community that's only shared
interest
is orange man bad which creates the
narrative and keeps it per it
it fuels the hatred for trump trump
needed to own
trump should have done two things left
twitter and went to parlor or mines or
any of these other platforms maybe
pocket net
and then shut up for a little bit you
should have made a youtube channel
he had one he had one well we should
have made daily video vlogs yep
that would that would be amazing i think
he should have said anything
he no he over communicated yes he did
that was his biggest
issue if you've got someone who is
delivering and this is
a covert assad you're killing it on the
community
in the economy just you're absolutely
killing it from a conservative
perspective you are delivering on judges
you've got foreign policy decisions that
generally are accepted by folks on the
right
people needed a reason to vote against
that yep
and he would give it too often not
always his fault
but he didn't he made it too easy i'm
starting to think that a lot of
politicians a lot of people
in the media are understanding that the
more extreme you could
make a situation the more extreme
language you could use
the more emotional ammunition you have
but they keep forgetting that this leads
to also extreme actions and they don't
really understand
the full kind of ramifications behind it
and they're caught in this loop
trying to get all the attention trying
to get all the clicks and i would say
you know donald trump especially with
some of his more bombastic
style was was also a part of that as
much as alexandria ocasio-cortez now i
know people like to label these people
as kind of populists
but also their strongest asset that that
people believe that there that makes
them that makes people believe that
they're populist
i believe is also their achilles heel
which should be understood in context
here as well i was just do you guys see
that uh picture of kathy griffin holding
trump's head
beheaded yeah i'm not familiar it just
started being recycled
kathy griffin this comedian and but i'll
tell you just
so if you don't know look it up kathy
griffin trump's head
uh did a photo shoot where she was like
and she was like in the middle of the
shoot she was like let's just do this
and
held up trump's bloody head as if that's
not in citation to violence like
no spinning things towards what they've
become and she didn't get banned off
twitter
she got fired from cnn well she didn't
get banned off twitter and she had a
mental breakdown and was like my life is
over and she was crying and begging for
her job back she went nuts
and then she doubled down later because
her life's already destroyed but look
think about the level of psychosis on
the left you have to get to before they
actually do anything
she's still on twitter after posting
that like like you were saying
on the right you could say learn to code
gone yeah
like that was really a i mean
it was a free artistic expression i
suppose
to hold the president's head up all the
bloody and beheaded if you want to do it
with biden would that be okay now
well i think someone already tried it
would bite in and was taken down yeah
did that right yeah i'm not surprised i
remember hearing something i was
surprised it is free expression and it's
also odious
there you go yeah and it can i think it
contributed to like
to this capital riot i think what we
need now
is the next person that needs to leave
office
is probably ocasio-cortez because i
think she might be one of the most
high-profile and bombastic politicians
we have
i think she's very very much like trump
i mean you look at the things
she says that we were just talking about
where she's like i narrowly escaped
death my colleagues
are white supremacists who might kill me
it's like dude you're making it all
worse calm down
lauren beaubert is not a white
supremacist she's not going to hurt you
she's just a five foot tall woman who
wants to have a gun people have guns
lots of them calm down yeah but i mean
she is acting the way that you would
expect someone that age to
act on social media that it's all is
lauren
the same age is she uh i think she's a
little bit older actually she's got
three points but still like they're both
you know uh i think you know aoc's in
her early 30s lauren's in her mid-30s
she's a millennial and that's generally
not all millennials
that is generally how millennials act on
social media sure
this idea that she's somehow you know
against type she
arguably she's going i don't care how
she acts the issue is
we need everybody to chill out yes and
start talking
and she is setting things on fire and
don't get me wrong
trump did too i think she's very much
like trump okay
now trump's been banned from everything
and they're all cheering for it okay
great if if we're going to be banning
people then she's got to get banned too
because she says inflammatory
stuff now the left defends her and
they'll be like that's not true of
course on the right defense trump i
don't care
listen you don't get to act like you are
absolutely perfect
they can come out and say trump's got to
go because he's inflammatory
and simply by saying remember this day
he's inciting violence
okay well then when aoc comes out and
says republicans are white supremacists
who are going to kill me
what do you think is going to happen if
she keeps saying that when she keeps
saying that
what about when she referred to the
immigration centers as concentration
camps and double down
i'm not i'm not gonna say she should be
banned for that okay what i'm saying is
she's allowed to her opinions and i
think she's crazy but when you have
people who are claiming
trump is the problem and she's doing
basically the exact same thing
are you gonna call her out next no
they're not they're gonna defend her
yeah and
and a lot of this is the responsibility
of the media because
the truth of the matter is those of us
who are on twitter
uh we are still few and far between who
pay that close attention to most of this
tucker carlson uh most watched cable
news show in history
is not reaching hundreds of millions of
people right
and so the average person i don't think
is getting this information they are
aware of who she is because she's really
good at building her brand
they probably have an opinion of her but
i bet you if you ask them some
specific questions probably couldn't
answer them about her
and the same i mean we know about donald
trump you go to a college campus we've
all seen the stupid videos you ask
a bunch of questions and no one knows
what they're doing so i think that's the
average person
and so that's really on the media to
sort of step up and start reporting this
more
and it can't just be fox news it can't
just be
one-offs here and there they have to
actually commit to it and they're just
not going to
tucker was the the biggest uh show in
cable
until he came out against sydney powell
or just questioned the evidence
and then his ratings got cut in half and
now fox news is dead last
is that isn't that crazy i mean it's not
it's not necessarily a bad thing what
happened was
when fox news challenged sydney powell
tucker carlson was like where's the
evidence and everybody fled
they went to oan and newsmax so there's
some diversification among conservative
news channels
what it really reveals is that well fox
news may have been number one at the
time
in terms of conservative content it was
dead last just because
there was only one channel one channel
means all the conservatives go there
so you got abc nbc cbs msnbc
all these networks and their left
perspective
there's substantially more viewers on
the left perspective than the right
that's been that it's been that way for
for a long time except i think in talk
radio i don't think left has an
equivalent of
anything integrity they tried and they
failed uh many times there's
been i think because you can get the
content
anywhere else what do you mean the
left leaning and flat out left content
you get everywhere everywhere right
right and so that they did not get
involved in the radio side
early enough they weren't able to really
defeat
what conservative talk radio has built
now there's some there are some
exceptions to that
around the country thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you